To be precise, the input is
two positive integer A and N for which the GCD is equal to one,
and the output is the
smallest positive integer R such that A to the power R is
congruent to one modular N,
or equivalently the
smallest positive integer R for which A to the R is equal to one.
Assuming we're doing arithmetic in ZN.
This is believed to be a
computationally difficult problem, no efficient classical algorithm
is known for solving it.
And as we'll discuss the problem is at least as hard as
integer factorization in the sense that if we have an algorithm for solving order finding,
we would be able to use that algorithm to solve the integer
factorization problem efficiently.
In fact, it goes the other way as well, meaning that if you happen to have an algorithm for factoring, you can use it to solve
the order finding problem.
So the two problems are
in some sense equivalent in terms of their
computational difficulty.
Now we'll see how we can solve
the order finding problem on a quantum computer
using phase estimation.
To make a connection between the problems, let's imagine that we have a system whose classical state set is AN.
For any choice of an element A in ZN star, we'll define an operation
MA like we have here.
In words what MA does is to multiply by A, and here the multiplication is modular N.
And for the remainder of this lesson, you should always think about
expressions inside of cats as being computed modular N,
just so we can keep things simple and we don't have to keep on
writing mod N over and over.
This is a unitary operation, but that's only true
because A is in ZN star.
If the GCD of A and N isn't one, this operation won't be unitary.
Here's an example. If N is equal to 15 and A is equal to two, which is in Z 15 star, then
this is the action of M two.
And if you examine this
example for a few moments, you'll see that what's happening is that the elements of ZN are just getting permuted by this action.
So it's both deterministic and unitary, which is to say that as a matrix, MA is a permutation matrix.
And here's the main idea. The eigenvalues of MA are
very closely connected
with the order of A. And by using phase estimation to approximate these
eigenvalues closely enough
we can determine the order of A. So what exactly are the eigenvectors and the eigenvalues of MA?
Well, we're not going to need all of them, we only need some of them.
Let's start off with an easy example.
Here's an eigenvector of MA, we've named it size zero, and it's given by the
sum of cat one, cat a,
cat A squared, and so on up to cat A to the power R minus one, all divided by the square root of R
to make it a unit vector. Here R is the order of A.
And I'll reserve the
letter R for the order of A for the rest of the lesson.
So whenever you see R, that's the order of A for
whatever A we're talking about.
The eigenvalue associated
with this eigenvector is one.
And we can verify that by
applying MA to this vector to see what we get.
MA multiplies by A, so
we just need to increase each of the exponents by
one and this is what we get.
But the order of A is R, so A to the power R equals one.
And we can make that substitution.
But that's the same vector
that we started with. All we've done is to
shuffle the cuts around but we're taking the sum so
this doesn't change anything.
So MA times psi zero is equal to psi zero.
So it's an eigenvector of
MA with eigenvalue one.
That's a very simple
example of an eigenvector and to identify more of them, let's recall the same notation that we had earlier in the lesson.
Omega R is the complex
number on the unit circle we get by taking E to the
power of two times pi times I
divided by R. Last time we had an N rather than an R, but it still works the same
way for R in place of N.
We need this number because
it's going to be appearing in the other eigenvectors
of MA that we'll identify.
And now that we've recalled that notation, we can observe that this
vector named psi one is also an eigenvector of MA.
It's similar to psi zero, we have exactly the same cats and we're summing them up and
dividing by the square of R.
But this time we have various phases multiplying each of the cats.
Omega R to the negative one for A, omega R to the negative two for A squared, and so on up to omega R to
the power negative R minus one
for A to the power R minus one. So the power of omega R
is always negative one times whatever power of A
appears inside of the cat.
I won't go through it in detail, but it is shown on the screen in case you'd like to re-watch the video and pause as needed.
But if we do the multiplication and we simplify again using the fact that A to the power R is equal to one
as well as the very important fact that omega to the power R is equal to one, what we'll find is that we
again have an eigenvector of MA.